from sci-fi Sidekicks to Cowboys on the
Move these iconic film characters lost
their lives while the cameras weren't
there to catch it the death that
Chadwick Boseman of complications from
colon cancer was as shocking as it was
devastating Not only was the actor just
43 years old at the time of his passing
but his diagnosis wasn't revealed to the
public until he was already gone those
who knew Bozeman best said that in
addition to Simply being a private
person it was his nature to worry about
others before himself and the last thing
he would have wanted was to have people
feel sorry for him
with pre-production for a second solo
Black Panther movie already underway at
the time of Bozeman's death questions
about how to proceed without him
immediately started to arise recasting
him was ruled out almost immediately as
was having him come back in CGI form
instead it was decided that king
t'challa would also pass away in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
t'challa ultimately loses his battle
with an unspecified illness setting the
stage for his sister shuri to become the
mcu's New Black Panther the on-screen
funeral in Black Panther wakanda forever
is a touching tribute to both the actor
and his most famous character
comedian George Carlin spent much of his
career almost constantly doing stand-up
tours leaving little time for anything
else especially acting but he did make
space in his busy schedule for a few
film appearances over the years the most
famous of which is his role as the time
traveling guide Rufus in the first two
Bill and Ted movies the third
installment in the series just stated
for a long time before it finally went
into production but Carlin had already
died by the time any serious talks in
making the three-quote were underway
that said it wasn't necessarily a
foregone conclusion that we wouldn't see
Rufus again in Billings had faced the
music the last few years have seen
several departed actors virtually
resurrected to reprise roles as famous
characters and for a time a CG George
Carlin was indeed considered for face
the music that was ultimately scrap
partially due to limited time and budget
but archival footage of Carlin dubbed
over with the sound alike was used so
Rufus could make one final cameo
it's just a hologram of Rufus at a
museum and the real Rufus died a few
years prior to the point in time that
Bill and Ted are visiting but it's a
sweet moment nonetheless the excellent
to each other
after all the bombastic action and the
climax of The Matrix wraps up the only
surviving crew members of the
Nebuchadnezzar are Neo Morpheus and
Trinity
and tank
remember tank played by Marcus Chung
tank is the operator of the heroes's
hovercraft in the first movie and he
heroically saves Neo in Trinity's lives
by killing their former Ally Cipher if
it wasn't for tank there would be no
Matrix Reloaded or Matrix Revolutions
but the character did not survive to see
the sequels tank apparently died during
an unseen mission prior to the Matrix
Reloaded the specifics of his death are
never mentioned outright but some fans
speculate that he succumbed to the
lightning rifle wound he received during
cypher's failed Mutiny tank was replaced
with an operator named link who was
apparently his brother-in-law rumor has
it that Chong was originally set to
appear in The Matrix sequels but he
demanded a much higher salary than the
one outlined in his contract after Chung
was let go he didn't take it well he
claimed to have crash press junkets
stolen food from production offices and
crank called the wachowskis he also
accused The Sibling directors of calling
him a terrorist and straight up sued
them for going back on a promise to let
him appear in the sequels
not every off-screen death comes as a
result of problem actors or tragic
losses sometimes it's just a perfect
storm of poor choices no off-screen
death is a better example of this
frustrating phenomenon than that of
Scott Summers the hero more commonly
known as Cyclops in X-Men the Last Stand
after returning to the final resting
place of his late fiancee Jean Gray
Summers is astonished to find her alive
well and rising from the water the two
Embrace and share a kiss at which point
Scott's skin starts to Ripple and his
eyes pop open in fear it turns out that
this isn't really Jean Gray at least not
the one Scott knew and loved to make a
long story short her presumed death
during the events of X2 leads to the
Awakening of her alternate personality
the Phoenix Phoenix assumes control of
Gene's body killing Cyclops and becoming
a general nuisance for the rest of the
film that's all well and good but it
would have been nice to actually see
what goes down at Alkali Lake all we get
is a shot of the other X-Men finding the
Cyclops Shades near an unconscious Gene
you could say that the Phoenix Got Away
scot-free
how do you soften up a guy who gets paid
to Pummel other men into mince meat give
him a quirky and endearing love interest
that's how it's hard not to fall in love
with the mousy Pet Shop worker Adrian in
the Rocky movies played by Talia Shire
arguably the heart and soul of the
franchise Adrian was never afraid to
speak up when her Meathead husband would
set himself up to get inviscerated like
when he challenged the six and a half
foot tall Ivan Drago to a match
regardless of Rocky's poor decision
making though Adrian was loyal to Rocky
until the very end
I'm with you no matter what
no matter what unfortunately thanks to
an off-screen death between Rocky 5 and
Rocky Balboa we're not exactly sure when
that end was the sixth film picks up
with Rocky living on his own with Adrian
apparently long dead at least she gets
an Italian restaurant named after her
with Rocky Balboa seeing the iconic
fighter as a tired weathered shadow of
his former self it's Adrian's absence
that gives Sylvester Stallone's
Performance Real dramatic weight
Stallone claims he wanted to cut out
Rocky's Heart by taking Adrian from him
and that's exactly what he did
after spending almost two entire films
being endlessly knocked down by life
things seem to be looking up for Dante
Hicks at the end of Clerks too
Chief among the reasons why he can be
excited for his future is that he's
finally realized his current fiance Emma
is wrong for him and that is dream girl
Becky has been right in front of him the
whole time with both the announcement of
Rosario Dawson's return is Becky and
clerks 3. it was easy to assume that
they were still on the road to living
happily ever after
however the audience has thrown a
devastating curveball when it's revealed
that Becky was actually killed by a
drunk driver sometime between the events
of Clerks 2 and clerks 3. while she was
pregnant with Dante's child it turns out
that Becky's presence and clerks 3 is at
times Dante dreaming about her in other
times her literally speaking to him from
the afterlife encouraging him to stop
being sad about losing her and start
learning to be happy without her
to live while you can love while you can
Vin Diesel may be most famous nowadays
for his many appearances in the Fast and
Furious movies but Dominic Toretto isn't
his only death-defying Action Hero in
XXX Diesel's Xander cage is an
adrenaline junkie who's been recruited
by the US government to prevent a
terrorist attack
XXX was a surprise hit earning over a
quarter billion dollars at the box
office naturally the studio wanted to
crank out a sequel and they weren't
going to let anything stop them not even
the loss of Xander himself after Diesel
turned down the chance to reprise his
role production went full steam ahead
with Ice Cube in his place
despite being directed by Lee tomahori
of Die Another Day Fame xXx State of the
Union was a flop fans didn't want Darius
Stone they wanted Xander cage but State
of the Union reveals that Diesel's
athlete turned agent apparently died in
Bora Bora after State of the Union
bombed the XXX series was put on ice
over a decade later though diesel in
action thriller veteran DJ Caruso
collaborated on a third entry in the
franchise in 2017. that aptly named XXX
return of Xander cage without any
explanation for his resurrection Xander
was back in action with his biggest
adventure yet the flick garnered mix
reviews from critics but for the fans
who had been waiting 15 years to see
Diesel's homecoming as the monotone
super spy it proved to be incredibly
satisfying casual viewers probably
remember the original Halloween as a
showdown between Michael Myers and
Laurie Strode but true fans know that
the real protagonist and lead character
of the first film was actually Dr Samuel
Loomis Dr Loomis is Myers's psychiatrist
turned primary pursuer and actor Donald
Pleasence received top billing for his
efforts his legacy among horror fans is
strong even if he often takes a backseat
to Jamie Lee Curtis death has come to
your little town sheriff you can either
ignore it or you can help me to stop it
considering that Loomis lived on after
the death of Donald Pleasence via
different actors there was more than
enough room for the good doctor's return
in the 2018 Halloween reboot however
considering that the 2018 movie takes
place 40 years after the original Dr
Loomis would be somewhere around 90
years old so the choice was made to have
the character die off screen replaced by
a new psychiatrist who studied under
loomis's tutelage it's never revealed
what his cause of death was but
considering his age it's likely that no
foul play was involved
the Terminator was one of the most
exciting films to come out of the 1980s
instantly cementing the name Sarah
Connor in the who's who of American pop
culture Terminator 2 Judgment Day upped
the ante in terms of character
development transforming Linda
Hamilton's character into a gun-toting
badass dedicated to Preparing her son
John for his future as the human
resistance leader against the evil
Skynet
T2 wound up earning a number of Academy
Awards for its technical achievement and
found immediate critical and Commercial
Success so when Terminator 3 rise of the
Machines finally emerged from
development hell in 2003 longtime fans
expected their favorite waitress turned
Warrior to blast onto the screen with
guns ablazon but she never showed
instead the movie reveals that Sarah
Connor died of leukemia between the
second and third films
it was Hamilton's choice to leave the
franchise as she claimed that her
character Arc and T3 would have been
insignificant compared to the first two
films she told MTV in 2009 she died
halfway through and there was no time to
mourn her it was kind of disposable so I
said no thank you
Hamilton returned to the franchise for
the first time since 1991 for Terminator
dark fate but even the resurrection of
Sarah Connor threw fourth dimensional
Shenanigans couldn't stop it from being
one of the biggest box office bombs of
that year
I'll be back
the Coen brothers are the kings of
subverting tropes and toying with
audience expectations No Country for Old
Men the neo-western Thriller based on
Cormac McCarthy's novel of the same name
is perhaps their most critically
acclaimed Thriller among a filmography
full of genre bending modern Classics
it's also their most blatantly
nihilistic with a depiction of oblique
bloody Texas in which the film's
protagonist Llewellyn Moss is killed off
screen one fateful day Moss goes out
hunting but instead of pronghorns he
finds 2.4 million big ones along with a
handful of dead gangsters Moss takes the
money and runs but Psychopathic Hitman
ants and [__] who's tasked with
reclaiming the cash tracks our hero from
hotel to hotel until poor Llewellyn
meets his maker there's also a complex
plot involving a bounty hunter played by
Woody Harrelson and a trail of bodies
unlucky enough to find themselves on the
business in a chiggers captive bolt
pistol but at its core No Country for
Old Men is a bloody game of cat and
between [__] and Moss that ends with
moss eating a bag of bullets courtesy of
the Mexican Mob however instead of a
first-hand account of the Carnage we
only get a brief glimpse of the
aftermath through Sheriff Belle's eyes
just before he eats his first
post-retirement breakfast
Cena was a fan favorite character in
both the Hunger Games books and movies
responsible for giving Katniss her
various Capital approved makeovers
musician Lenny Kravitz took on the part
when the series came to the big screen
and he proved to be just as capable an
actor as he is a singer I'm not allowed
to bet
Cena is one of Katniss's only true
supporters when she's been whisked away
from her District 12 home even though he
knows he's literally risking his life to
be your friend
in fact their bond is used as
psychological warfare against Katniss
when she's forced to watch Senna be
brutally beaten just moments before
having to begin her Second Battle Royale
Katniss knows that the capital probably
isn't done punishing him for being kind
to her and sure enough Effie Trinket
later breaks the news to Katniss that
Cena has been killed even in a film
series where off-screen deaths are the
norm and happen often cinez's demise is
the most heartbreaking of all it's not
very common to see a major Studio movie
starring gay characters nowadays but it
was almost unheard of prior to 2005.
that was the year that angley's
devastating Love Story Brokeback
Mountain was released to the public
bringing in eight Academy Award
nominations and serious cash at the box
office
centering Around The Fearless
performances of Jake Gyllenhaal as Jack
twist and the late Heath Ledger as Innis
Del Mar Brokeback Mountain follows two
Cowboys who begin a passionate love
affair kept secret from the rest of the
world for decades naturally having to
live a life for that long eats away at
both of them and causes major turmoil
within each of their respective lives as
they deceive their friends family wives
and children any chance that they might
have had to be together for real is
dashed when Innis learns of Jack's death
allegedly from an accident involving an
exploding car tire
Ennis imagines that Jack was probably
beaten to death by bacon which is shown
on screen but the movie doesn't
explicitly state that this is what
actually happened only that it's innis's
worst case scenario the truth the Jack's
passing is never fully revealed
he may not be as well known as the more
famous members of the Corleone family
but Peter clemenza has one of the most
memorable and funniest lines in The
Godfather
leave the gun
technically played by Richard Castellano
clemenza is a fiercely loyal Capo who
plays an important role in Michael
Corleone's rise to power despite being a
prominent character in the film he
didn't return for The Godfather Part 2.
except through flashbacks to his younger
self played by actor Bruno Kirby instead
he is said to have succumbed to a heart
attack at some point between the
timeline of the two films although there
is some skepticism from some of the
other characters as to whether he died
of natural causes or was murdered either
way the reason Peter went from major
character to off-screen death was a
result of creative differences between
Richard Castellano and Godfather
director Francis Ford Coppola this
ultimately LED Castellano to quit the
franchise and soon after acting
altogether
after the events of aliens Ellen Ripley
finds herself with a potential new love
interest and a surrogate daughter in
Corporal Hicks and little Newt
respectively after surviving the
xenomorph Queens assault the three along
with the badly damaged Android Bishop
enter hypersleep in preparation to
return to Earth
except much like in most Alien movies
things don't go according to plan James
Cameron's aliens may end on an
optimistic note but Alien 3 is David
Fincher territory and if you've seen
zodiac or seven you may know where this
is going due to an alien face hugger
hidden on the ship the four survivors
are launched onto the surface of a
prison planet Newt drowns inside of her
Escape pod and Hicks well there's not
much left of hicks after his pot is
impaled by a support beam incredibly
brutal and profoundly depressing the
instant collapse of Ripley's Newfound
family was viewers first indication that
this wasn't the same kind of film as
aliens sure Alien 3 wasn't a
particularly great film as Fincher
himself has admitted but it returned the
series to its horror roots with gut
stuff
the Coen Brothers may be known for their
subversions of popular genres but their
2010 remake of True Grit is a straight
up No Frills traditional Western
still it manages to be impressively
heartwarming and surprisingly funny
thanks to the PowerHouse performances
from Jeff Bridges and Haley Steinfeld
the latter of whom was just 13 years old
during production their characterist
Rooster Cogburn and Maddie Ross don't
quite get along at first but they
develop a strong connection as they
attempt to track down a murderous Outlaw
I'm a foolish old man who's been drawn
into a wild goose chase by a harpy and
trousers and a nincompoop the chemistry
of the unlikely pear is natural and
entertaining and it's thanks to their
bond that they're able to make it back
home with their lives after that they
don't see each other for 25 years but a
grown-up Maddie decides to change that
after she receives a flyer for his Wild
West Chef she's tragically late however
as she learns that he passed away just
three days prior to her arrival
even though the two never get their
joyful reunion Maddie is content to
reminisce about the difficult but
memorable time they've spent together
foreign
[Music]